-Here at "Late Night,"
every night,
I deliver a monologue
comprised of jokes
written by a diverse team
of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight, white male,
would be difficult
for me to deliver.
But we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so we'd like to share them
with you
in a segment we call
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Duct tape rips ]
Hey, everybody.
These are two of our writers.
That's Amber,
and that's Jenny.
-I'm black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So, here's how this works.
I'll read the set-ups
for the jokes,
and then Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines,
so here we go.
The longest-running lesbian bar
in the United States
recently closed for good.
-So now lesbians will have to
meet the old-fashioned way --
at Ace Hardware.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-18,000 contaminated pipes
in Flint, Michigan,
will be replaced
by a black-owned
construction company.
-And it's true what they say --
their pipes are bigger.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
They are.
-A lesbian was recently
named the leader
of Germany's Fascist party.
-If you're wondering
what lesbians and Fascists
have in common,
the answer is their haircut.
[ Laughter ]
-Jenny -- Jenny, why is it
that so many lesbians
have short haircuts?
-We just get really excited
about scissors.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Audience "Oh"s ]
-Jenny!
Jenny, no!
[ All chuckle ]
[ Laughter ]
According to a recent article...
According to a recent article,
there's been an increase
in women using smartphone apps
to track their menstrual cycles.
-Still no word on how
they get those phones in there.
[ Laughter ]
I guess you put it down there --
-No! No! No! No!
[ Laughter ]
I wasn't pausing for an answer.
-Oh.
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
On the popular British
soap opera "EastEnders,"
a lesbian character recently
decided to sleep with a man.
-I guess she got tired
of having orgasms.
[ Audience "Oh"s ]
-Are lesbians really that good
at giving orgasms?
-Watch this.
[ Snaps fingers ]
-[ Gasps ]
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're welcome.
-[ Chuckles ]
Wow!
[ Laughter ]
I've never heard that noise
or seen that face.
[ Laughter ]
According to a recent article,
home ownership among
black Americans is 30% lower
than home ownership
among white Americans.
-Lucky me, because I got
this brick...
[ Humming funky beat ]
...house.
[ Laughter ]
♪ She's mighty, mighty ♪
♪ Just lettin' it all hang out ♪
♪ She's a brick, mm-mm ♪
-♪ House ♪
-Hey, you know it!
All right.
Just that part.
A gay couple recently kissed
on the Kiss Cam
at Dodger Stadium.
-While a lesbian couple
was too busy watching the game.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Hey, Seth,
why don't you tell one.
-Me?
Nooooo.
No, I -- I couldn't.
-Aw.
-I couldn't possibly tell one.
-Yeah. Oh, come on, just one.
-Well, I feel like if I tell
one, I'm gonna get in trouble.
That's how it always happens.
-Come on, just do it!
-Okay, but I can fully trust
you guys?
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah.
-You guys will both have my back
if I do this?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-The adult website PornHub
announced recently
that its most popular category
of all time is "lesbian"
and its least-popular category
is "real-life lesbian."
-[ Gasps ]
-How dare you?!
[ Laughter ]
-You should be ashamed
of yourself!
-You promised me
it would be okay!
-But I am a real-life lesbian.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
[ Duct tape rips ]
[ Cheers and applause ]